bonsoir la guinguette à dessous c'était
un roman de georges simenon ce soir il y
a la gagne est rétro de la gare d'eau à
besançon
tout cela pour clore la saison du
groupement pour le tourisme fluvial le
gts s'est fait le promoteur des 340 km
de voies navigables en franche comté
vous avez eu l'occasion de suivre
plusieurs reportages à ce sujet durant
tout l'été
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du bilan et la
fête surtout à deux pas d'ici où nous
retrouvons michel lelong bien eh oui
michel busan nous sommes ici à quelques
mètres des studios de notre station de
fr3 sur les bords du doubs près de la
gare d'eau ou depuis 14 heures une
grande manifestation une grande fête
nautique a été organisée par le
groupement du tourisme fluvial jacques
aux ténois le président claude fabert
alors président qu'est ce qui s'y passe
ici et que vous l'avez dit c'est une
manifestation nautique et mais surtout
une grande guinguette une grande
guinguette avec des partis qui se passe
sur l'eau promenade en bateau sur la
barge de l'association du rivage et sur
les petits bateaux des adhérents et
aussi les démonstrations vous avez pu
voir comme cette nouvelle planche à
voile son voile à la plancha peine
inventé par un franc comtois fiona
pareil pour nager quand on ne sait pas
nager qui est aussi un prototype de
l'inventeur franc comtois d'arbois
d'ailleurs et vous avez pu également
voir une démonstration de deux maquettes
de bateaux de modèles réduits dont la
reproduction du france qui fait deux
mètres de long et qui avec d'autres
bateaux de ce type la navy ont navigué
sur la doux pendant l'après-midi pour la
plus grande joie des spectateurs qui
d'ailleurs encore maintenant arrive
nombreux cet ascète guinguette rétro qui
est placée sous le signe de la frite la
friture et de l'accordéon dans l'entrée
gratuite l'entrée du site est gratuite
on dirait donc ce soir qu'est ce qui
place également
alors ce soir on peut toujours venir et
entrer gratuitement sur ce magnifique
site de la gare d'oslo zahlé de
marronniers où ira buvette les stands et
pas mal de jeux et d'attractions mais en
plus nous avons un bail un bal monter un
bal où tout à fait classique
traditionnelle est ce que nous avons
appelé le bal des canotiers heures en
espérant que beaucoup de bisontins de
francs comtois ainsi rendront avec au
moins avec ce sera l'accessoire 1900
1930 elle ce mal d'échos notiez est
installé là sur le site de la guinguette
et son entrée payante mais en face à 30
francs et vous oui en tout cas bonne
soirée michel et demain ça continue avec
le premier concours de ski nautique de
fond et puis aussi les mangeurs de
cancoillotte paraît-il